minecraft real life mind
you guys wanted me to play single-player
minecraft you didn't specify which one
just give me what gym should give me one
more day gamers for now we're playing
real life craft or a really light
likable craft I hope that's the name
everyone's been talking about I'm
playing this so let's just do it
apparently this mod is like regular
minecraft but harder a bunch of noobs do
you think minecraft is hard
it's like Minecraft but it's it's not a
freaking dragon right back so there ah
it's that a Griffin hey that it was our
new record let's try again
oh where am I in mine actual water uh
cool let's try that for the third time
here we go
cool whoa everything is so different oh
god it's got auto jump why on God's
earth would you want that on that's a
freaking turret pterodactyls thing
dinosaur Oh God
verdant maka hello merchant maka friend
friend Colver call me invert and macabre
friend friends okay trees look very
different I don't remember there being
the alien from Sarek in Minecraft that's
cool as a jungle more epic dinosaurs
there must be a nest here spend spend
are you in this this is awful
what are these buns are there stones
okay cool
all they make a sound it is pretty cool
actually it's pretty impressive how
different it is cool you can't break the
stone with a stone apparently wait what
are these what is happening whoa damn
this Oh what
why does nothing drop anymore so I think
what you need to do in this modest you
have to find they have the sound effects
so cool you have to find Flynn why am I
losing my inventory confuse Swedish
noises I'm sorry piggies is liver or let
die in this I'm going against dinosaurs
I ain't taking no chances
we're cool right we're cool right
dinosaurs how did you even survive in
this world this is ridiculous
I'm collecting stones now oh god it's a
castle
sheet set Pearlie prefer a well look and
I think you have to drink water in this
game slurp slurp say we're cool
I'm cool with the dinosaurs so far zero
deaths pretty epic okay I need to find
Flint
it's his Flint Flint Flint oh god what's
sexy hello
oh heck yeah Oh Frick yeah minecraft
I'll frickin all right so this is gravel
I think yes okay I found gravel cool so
we just need the flinty Flint so to pick
up items you hit shift or you're right
play dumb but I'm not getting any Flint
Flint
I forgot wood Oh God
is that good or evil good or evil okay
good it's good
anything that doesn't kill me I will
assume is on my side
oh we got a flint shard okay so now when
you we have a flint shard see I wonder
how I know this well I'm a Minecraft
veteran alright I know what I'm doing
that's cool why does it sound like I'm
wearing high heels I swear I swear I'm
not wearing high ears alright so you
just throw you throw the stone there you
go and then we got a Flint shard just
like real life why because this is real
life craft now we can go against the
dinosaur
I feel like I'm ready no that's not what
we're doing okay you get the Flint shard
what do you do next you take a stick and
you make knife and now we're ready for
dinosaurs now for real I'm doing amazing
here I've honestly never seen anyone
progress this fast so now we can shop
plant and make plant fiber why because
real life oh my god is [ __ ] I don't
like it this is fun I like this I'll say
that until I die basically okay
it's like minecraft easiest game of all
time okay so now we have a banana plant
the fiber and we can make plants string
why because it's just like real life
and then we can make dough okay yeah I
have to shop these to get sticks I think
the other one I found in nature there it
is
stick stick okay we have to find spend
in this world any world I'll find him
did I do it
there it is hatchet okay cool I think
we're doing good chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop god this is
useless
hello hello Oh what is this seed Wow
minecraft that's awesome ah what do I do
with see they plant oh I need hole okay
interesting summer autumn what there's
seasons in Minecraft okay shut up
so now we have a cache of wood we
flip-flop them shut
actually I prefer when it's quiet and
then I think right click chop
oh I did it that gives us two how you
need to do it again oh god this is gonna
get old fast okay three oh my lord
all right let's speed up a bit all right
shop shop shop shop shop okay now make a
workbench gosh damn I'm good at this
game that's what you sound like farting
noises then I have a bunch of stones oh
yeah you can make a cobblestone out of
stone epic I think epic and I I know
this because I'm Minecraft veteran and
you can make us a knife I thought you
could make a knife maybe you need fiber
I think I'm hearing someone farting or
it's just something worse I have dagger
oh okay it's you it's my sex is my
minecraft wife but I think she's pretty
old do I bring this with me sure wanna
it's pretty nice house now what do I do
here I guess I'll make armor I don't
know I'm so lost
it sucked to die now when I spent all
this effort okay well fine I'll build a
house here this is my house what it's
making that noise there's bees in
Minecraft world I just want to know if
these guys are friendly or not that's
all I want to know hey we cool
check your beastie Chiba
I ain't checking I ain't checking okay
let's make it that sound I think we are
cool
can I ride you that's the real question
you're not spending but I say it's you I
still kiss you what doesn't kill me if
you don't like it no you like it I kiss
everyone
okay five more gamers it's getting dark
and I kind of don't want to be ill it's
hard enough during the day so I think
I'm gonna go bye-bye
I'm gonna go bye-bye for a little while
I don't like that block it looks like a
creeper and I want to frickin I'll set
it and I'll say it again the Minecraft
creeper block is sexy Jesus what that's
a frickin lie ad that's up break it up
stop but not douse my house stink you
stink
haha oh God oh all right I have a dagger
it's okay yes yes yes yes
you staying oh god yes a lot of help you
can't come in my house why you smell
right so where were we don't engage with
Tiger got it
alright okay understandable
understandable I don't think that's the
sound you for cobblestone I need to make
a furnace I can cook this chicken I'm
using the stones to break the stones
gamers how epic is this can you make
stone armor in this game let's look at
the stuff you can make you can make it
em mithril what what stone that stone
okay if you can make stone dagger
Shirley wolf or what I can make armor
for ah I can make iron armor for spend
stolen armor question mark what the
Frick is in our room maybe I should just
may stick to leather oh my god even the
sounds it's all coming back
it's a tiger gone that's a no dammit
dammit ah all right where am what is
happening I broke my work my mouse sorry
Mouse this is still work oh god what is
did I fix it I fixed it so Swedish
engineering gamers okay well that was
that level I wasn't too attached so it's
fine oh you know what just from I
changed my mind
no house all right here we are under the
ocean again what were you born on daddy
okay I think we're onto something this
looks normal
I don't see any Tigers I don't see any
dinosaurs I don't see any giant skeleton
things this is nice it's like a Swedish
Birchwood burek as we say in Sweden this
could be yeah yeah yeah we can pluck
virus [ __ ] [ __ ]
nice nice no sexy you minecraft wives No
I'm just gonna go this way what in the
world hello are you nicer or evil he's
cool alright nice well live here oh cool
magma demon just spawned hey hey he's
trying to kill me
we're cool
starting to understand why Auto jumping
was on just kidding it was a trap joke
if you're laughing with me you're dead
so cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap
cheap I won't kill you
cheap cheap cheap cheap I really like
the sound effects makes me feel like I'm
playing a rhythm game minecraft rhythm
game makes me forget that I'm actually
murdering innocent ship ship
okay now we just need to find Flynn
someone try to make a cobblestone
generator dumb it's not even how you do
it there's turkeys in Minecraft haha
cool turkey be like dead can you ride
the dinosaurs don't answer if you know
the answer oh we found it Flint is minty
can wait for the abundance of comments
telling me how to play telling me how
I'm playing this game wrong alright we
got to throw these planets something
hard why are your mama peepee here we go
cool why am i or blurry oh I'm thirsty
as Frick boy why do I get those thirsty
what do I throw away can't slurp
okay low-key kind of love this bed not
gonna lie
timber then we spread it out like a
sandwich and we shop it does it have to
be all the same type of wool are you
kidding me duh oh there you are there
you are mr. what the Sheep the door all
right cool
that's enough that's a nice I don't
understand you can die in this game
embarrassing is that my stomach am I
getting hungry oh god I like a I got raw
turkey if I get really bad if it gets
really bad okay we need to make us
frickin bed not a bed for frickin but a
freak okay you catch my drift gamer slip
say Frick I can't sleep okay I got to
survive until 9:00 Oh God
what's my best option here dig straight
down come on
sleep sleep I'm so hungry I need to slay
hate I don't thank god yes
good morning gamers I'm hungry I'm tired
but I ain't giving it a name tag I found
it I found things named bad guys yes
huh I'm very very hungry mungry I'm very
hungry mungry looking for food Oh God
yes yes yes yes perfect perfect yes
we're gonna live gamers yes oh oh yes
yes yes yes
how can you dine this mod pathetic okay
I need enough for my cobblestone gym I
don't trust anything okay that should be
enough right yeah we got enough I might
as well make one on this side as well
okay and now we make cookie smoky cookie
cookies monkey puck cookies with your
cookie and singing there my Schuch I'm
so sorry for this
oh god I'm so hungry gamers oh my god
num num num num num num num delish mmm
mmm such a good dish all right let's
find Bengt and give him back his nametag
there's a house there let's do what the
Viking did pillage that's what they did
they pillage you just got to scream
really confidently when you are no
nevermind
ah
Oh
what hello hey hey who wants the dead
that's what I thought there's a freaking
town there am i too hot I'm burning up
dude it's too hot in here bro
maybe they have a pool in here this is
cool Wow hey hey
oh god I'm dying I'm heated oh this is
super high do they have a pool
oh god I'm dying a pool I'm in water I
mean actual ahh thank God it's working
maybe cuz I pee pee a little
Hey look his Bell Delfina her and her
back I didn't know that they had it she
says what is that are we friends okay I
guess we're cool piston why it feels
like there's no point for me to bill in
the skin cuz everything I find is so
cool anyway gosh they're all so poor I
hear the dog I will find the dog he's
calling for me he needs to me spen I'm
coming I swore I swore I hear him
vain submit hain it alright gamers hope
you enjoyed that episode of really lie
lining ok goddamn I hope you guys
enjoyed that episode if you did smash
like subscribe merch see you tomorrow
bye bye